it's impossible to concentrate on an
empty stomach
15 year old devs relied on free school
meals for months
living in leicestershire half term was
this week he says he missed his school
food
it just that little bit of help which
means the world to my mom and dad and it
allows us to
keep on going and you know pay the
family bills but also me and my brother
having a good lunch
and coming back full for much of the
rest of the country half term begins
next week
when a campaign backed by footballer
marcus rashford and rejected by the
government
has galvanized local communities into
providing food
for families in need whatever this
situation is never the child's fault
and that is why at minikin art cafe we
are providing free hot meals to children
that need them
after that disappointing news yesterday
we stand shoulder to shoulder with
marxist rashford
to end child food poverty we just want
to help the kids that are missing out
and not having anything to eat
and we're overwhelmed by the response
that we've had there's an opportunity
for
some children to have a hot meal next
week a free meal
and there's absolutely no reason why
kids should be going hungry
at the moment it's not right that
children
should go hungry anytime alongside many
local councils
warren and andy's fruit and vegetables
one of hundreds offering free food to
children off
school who'd normally be entitled to
free meals
in term time we ain't hungry they are
and that at the end of the day if it
takes us a week's wages to pay for it
but we're up for doing it aren't we yeah
earlier this week ministers ruled out
extending free meals beyond term time
projecting calls to make them available
in holidays for the next six months
with the government defending that
decision what is the best way
of delivering support we think the nine
billion pounds that we put into the
welfare system
the billion pounds we put in to schools
for catch-up the
additional one billion pounds we've just
allocated to local authorities that is
not
ring fenced that builds on the earlier
3.7 billion pounds
we think those are better ways of
getting support to families
covid's hit families hard and in the
poorest areas
this issue is no longer just a political
football for many it's now
a moral cause adele robinson sky news